um welcome to
to the simon's quantum colloquium so
today we are following a slightly
different format
um so um uh
following last week's talk on quantum
fault tolerance by
daniel gottisman today we have another
talk on
on fault tolerance um or flag fault
tolerance
and so following that we'll have a panel
and
um uh you know we are great
really it's great that we have a
distinguished panel of uh
john martinez john prescott and and
peter shaw
so that will be immediately following
following the colloquium so at
in one hour and then the plan is for the
the panel to go for half an hour and
then following that will be
on gather town as usual so for more
in-depth uh discussions
so um let's see without further ado let
me
introduce our speaker today uh rachael
so roy is um is
is currently a postdoc at uh at duke
university
um he was he did his phd with ben
reichardt
where he introduced um in his work with
ben he introduced this notion of
flag fault tolerance which he'll which
he'll describe to us
today and um uh um
roy is actually uh going to be joining
uh
the simon's institute as a post talk uh
starting this fall
so uh so really really looking forward
to hearing
uh your talk please uh can you share
your
screen
can you see my slide
yes okay um great okay
um thank you so much umesh for the uh
introduction and
for giving me this opportunity to talk
uh and thanks everyone for coming
um today i will be talking about a
general
paradigm which is useful for optimizing
for tolerance schemes we call this
the flag paradigm so first
let me recall let us recall the
intuition for
fault tolerance so in general in order
to perform a quantum computation for
tolerantly
you need to simulate your circuit by
running a larger circuit
which is more robust to noise
specifically
you need to replace each gate or circuit
component
with the more reliable gadgets
consisting of
noisy components
the so-called flag gadgets is just a
technique
which allows you to construct these
gadgets
with a smaller qubit overhead
and this flag technique is actually a
general paradigm
which has many applications at below
is a list of works that use the flag
idea
to achieve fall tolerance in a variety
of tasks
such as error correction or magic state
preparation
the key idea behind the flag paradigm is
to use the so-called
flag gadgets to catch those malignant
falls in a circuit
and then remedy them
in this talk i will i've explained some
of the details
in these three papers that i have been
involved with
all these three papers are john works
with my phd advisor by red card
in the past few years when i was at uic
the first two papers uh proposed a flag
idea and
they were written like four years ago
the search paper is a more recent result
in this talk i will be mainly explaining
how to do
for tolerant and regression using flags
and i will only briefly mention other
flag applications by other researchers
so now let me first give some
background and motivation for the flag
as we have seen for several times for
tolerance is amazing because
it makes possible to perform large-scale
quantum computations
um for example suppose you want to uh
factor a
um to a 2000 bit rsa integer
or to simulate a femoco which is an
important molecule for
biological nitrogen fixation then
you're gonna need at least tens of
billions of quantum gates
thanks to the accuracy threshold zero
you don't need to drive the gate error
rate
of down to one of 10 million
and for small quantum chips which is a
set of art
either based on triple ions or
superconductors
the average infidelity of two cubic
gates
is typically one percent which is fairly
close to the
best fault tolerance threshold however
it seems that the biggest obstacle
towards fault tolerance
is not the poor gas fidelity but rather
the
huge overhead which is defined as the
ratio of a number of physical cubits
over the number of logical qubits
even if the gate error rate is below one
of
a thousand say we still need
several thousands of physical cubits to
encode a single
logical one
so a natural question is how can we
reduce the overhead incurred by fault
tolerance
this is a quite broad research field and
there are hundreds of papers on this
topic
most of this works focus on specific
building blocks of tolerance schemes
such as
syndrome extraction decoding algorithm
or state distillation most of this works
focus on specific building blocks
and each building block is a is already
fairly complicated to optimize and it's
even more complicated
to study the trade-off when you combine
them
and among this method i want to in
particular
mention a low-hanging fruit which is to
choose
efficient codes to work with at the very
beginning
for example we can simply encode
multiple logical queries into a
single code block such as the ldpc code
this gives a higher rates because it can
protect several cubits by a single run
of either correction
for a certain family of ldpc codes
we can actually achieve constant
overhead although
this mostly a theoretical result
the drawback for this idea is that it's
difficult to target on individual
logical queries in the
code block and the computer for them so
for now i don't think people have many
good approaches to handle this issue
previously a kind of general approach
for doing this
is based on teleportation so first we
teleport
several logical queries to their
individual empty code blocks
and then they will be easier to interact
over here and after that we have to
teleport them back to the
data block this is sort of
expensive because um we need ancillars
with the size of a code block and we
need extra answers to
prepare them in certain logical states
for tolerance
so it's really desirable to construct
efficient for tolerant operations for
general families of
blog codes or ldpc codes but i want to
emphasize that
it's also desirable to um optimize on a
specific
code uh phenomenal one should try
best to um to reduce the fault tolerance
over
overhead of a small code so that
experimentalists can
play with it on a small quantum device
for example
with tens of physical qubits
um it might come as a surprise that
although for tolerance is a is at the
heart of quantum computer
it has hardly been uh tested in
experiments
uh people actually have demonstrated
error correction protocols over
several of physical platforms
but they were uh they were not for
tolerance in the sense that
um a single gate failure uh in the whole
procedure can
uh can occur in a certain way that
propagates
and become an uncorrectable error
and in the past few years uh there have
been
uh several for tolerance experiments
on entraps or superconducting cubies
most of them are based on this
four qubits error detecting codes with
distance two
and they use one or more ancillars to
achieve fall tolerance
and recently um the drone group
uh from maryland and duke uh they
demonstrate for tolerance using
uh this nine qubit beacon shortcode uh
which can correct any single qubit error
and this is a quite a big achievement
uh they demonstrate uh they have tested
uh logical states preparation
environment
uh syndrome extraction logic states and
even
prepare magic state uh magic states
and for all these tasks they verify that
the fault tolerance circuits perform
better than the non-fault tolerant
burden
however i would say that for tolerance
they demonstrate
still have certain limitations for
example
the logical higher rates of the single
qubit gate is
somehow worse than a physical error rate
this is just because for
trapped ions the single cubic is much
better
than 2gb game so since um logical single
qubit
involves 2 cubic then it somehow has
worse
error rate also
in their experiments they were not able
to perform
intermediate measurements meaning all
cubes are measured simultaneously
at the end but in the long run we
definitely
need to be able to perform error
correction repeatedly
um so testing for tolerance
i think is a daunting task and i think
the reason
it's twofold first it's difficult to
engineer
uh reliable cubits uh with high fidelity
uh two cubic gates and low spam error
rate
and second reason is that the criteria
for for tolerance
is quite stringent and tricky to verify
and for this i really want to refer you
to
this paper by danny gordisman mirror he
gives a
fairly extensive discussion about
various
caveats and complications
i don't have time to explain
um this idea in detail but my point is
that
given such difficulties what we can do
is really to
start from small devices
this is quite beneficial and
also necessary to study because
a good test will allow us to demonstrate
the autonomous theory
and will help us better evaluate the
performance of different
autonomous schemes in practice and
this in turn will enable us to adapt our
schemes to realistic and noise models
um therefore uh i think it's important
for a series to come
on this good autonomous test to uh
for experimentalists and this is
basically
you know the motivation and the
background behind the flag idea
okay so here are some
small photons schemes using the flag
idea
so first for certain distance 3
stabilizer codes
only two extra activities are sufficient
for tolerance error correction
uh the simplest example is a five cubic
perfect code
we show that uh seven physical cubes are
enough to
protect the single electrical curves for
tolerantly
the more efficient example uh is the 15
qubit hamming code
we show that two ancillars are enough to
protect as many as
uh seven logical fields um
so now at this time uh you may wonder
why
people have not implemented this small
course
you know people have already have chips
uh with
uh 20 or even 50 cubits well the reason
is that uh here i only tell you the
number of physical cubies you need
but i don't tell you uh how you should
interact them
um in this flag schemes um
we require a single qubit to uh to be
able to talk to every other qubit
and this condition is quite challenging
to fulfill for
for many physical systems such as
superconducting googles
although such connective connectivity
issue
seems not exist for ion traps
these flag schemes also require reusing
insulin cubits
by repeatedly measure and prepare
and as far as i know um there might be
a very few ion trap groups
who are able to do such intermediate
environments
but their performance is quite unstable
so in other words flag schemes do have
certain
requirements for the hardware which need
to be satisfied simultaneously but
i do believe it will be very soon that
experimentalists
should tackle all these issues
okay besides this arrow correction one
thing much more interesting
we can do is to perform logical
computation
we show that with only these three uh
these two
ancillars you can already perform any
logical gates within the seven
qubit clifford group autonomously
and with another two cubits uh you can
actually perform any universal gig site
on this um semilogical cubits
and previously if we want to compute
over seven
logical qubits a reasonable plan is to
prepare seven blocks of sten's code and
compute over them
and you need at least four additional
answers for
example to um i will correct for
autonomously
so at least the 53 physical curb is
unnecessary
and now we show that to achieve this
task you only need
19 physical curious in total
the third result is a requestion scheme
that
that is applicable to arbitrary
stabilizer code
this small these small examples
um sorry these small examples
they are able to achieve from tolerance
with very few cubies
mainly because they only need to
tolerate a single circuit fault
but for higher distance you probably
need many more circuits for fault
tolerance
but here we show that uh if the code has
distance d
then you need at most the d plus one
ancillars in total
uh i should emphasize that this d plus
one is a
uniform upper bound for arbitrary the
arbitrary codes which might not be
types for specific values for example
when d equals to three and for specific
codes you need only
two ancestors so
the main idea behind all these protocols
are the same
that is to add gadgets which we call
flags
to those circuit locations where
certain bad powers could happen and if
such error does happen then the flag
gadget should signal us
alert and provided our flag edges have
been carefully designed
we should be able to crack the errors
next i will explain how to error correct
using distance three code using only two
ancestors
but before that uh let's review some
basics
about stabilizer called arrow correction
um in typical quantum level correction
uh the iris that we are concerned about
are bit flip error x
and the physical value of z
in particular x and z are related by a
conjugation of
hadamard matrix
to protect against a bit flip error
for example we can encode us arbitrary
qubit states alpha k0 plus beta cap 1
into this alpha 0 0 0 plus beta 1 1
1. similar to the classical reputation
codes
no matter what alpha and beta is the
parity
of any pair of the bits is even
or in the language of quantum mechanics
the eigenvalue of
c1 d2 and z2 d3 is always 1.
and these poly check operators are also
called
stabilizers suppose there
there's a x error on the second qubit
then
it will change the priority of the first
two bits or change the stabilizer
eigenvalues to
uh to minus one so we can correct a
single x error
by measuring this parity checks and the
extract its syndromes
similarly we can correct again we can
protect against
um a phase flip error by encoding
our qubit into a reputation code in the
hadamard basis
in this case the code word is stabilized
by
x1 x2 and x2 x3
and a single z error will flip the
syndrome bits of
at least one stabilizer
now let's see how we can measure the
syndrome bits
without destroying the code state for
example here is a circuit
that measures c1 z2 so you
you first prepare uh the answer of the
qubits in case zero states and uh
perform two
signals uh controlled on the first two
qubits
uh if there's um if there's no
bit flip on the code word then um
either the enceladus state is not played
or is flipped twice
so no matter what alpha and beta is at
the end of the
at the end um this ancelor will still be
k zero
however uh if the second qubit undergoes
a bit flip error
then the answer will be flipped exactly
once uh and
at the end you get a non-trivial
syndrome bit
by measuring the answer in the d basis
another way to verify
the behavior of this circuit
is by checking how poly errors
propagates through this
c naught case and in fact in some sense
for tolerance in general it's all about
how errors
how errors propagates through this multi
multitude of the gates so for c not
gates
we can see that x on the control
control valve will propagate to the
target
whereas the z error uh on the target
there will propagate onto the control
so um under the other case uh
the arrow does not spread
now let's see what happens if there is a
x error on the second qubit
so it will propagate through the c
naught
uh onto into our x error on the ancillar
which will flip k0 into k1 and result in
a non-trivial
measurement of com similarly
we can verify that the circuit on the
right
is a valid synchronous fraction for x1
x2
so it's a it's essentially the same as
the left circuit
except changing everything from the
standard basis
to the hardware basis so now let's see
how the replica um well no um
no um i have shown that uh
um this repetition code can craft a
single x or single z
error but in general we can construct
a stabilizer called that correct many
x z or even by errors uh
and here we use the notion of nkd
to denote an incubator stabilizer code
with k
encoded two bits which can correct any
quality errors
with weight at most half of d minus one
uh for the illustration purpose and also
result loss of generality uh in this
talk
uh we also only focus on
how to measure x type stabilizer i mean
denotes the the weights as w
um now let's take a closer look at the
circuits
uh that measures the stabilizer for
example x tensor
2 4 and see how
errors propagate within it as we have
seen
x type stabilizer can detect z errors
uh suppose a z error occurs here then it
will propagate
through the c knob into
and for our ancestor and resulting into
a non-trivial measurement here
as except as expected however
in practice errors not only occur on
this block
uh the syndrome extraction circuit
itself
is faulty uh for example
there could be a xbox in the middle of
the uh acid available
and it will propagate through the
subsequent
signals into into data cubits
and eventually this single circuit fault
will result in two correlated errors on
the data
if the underlying code can can only
correct one error namely
distance three then in this case a
single x false on the answer will
give rest to data address of bit two
which uh in general is uncorrectable for
distance three code and in this case uh
in this
in this sense we say this circuit is not
fault tolerant
uh more generally if you are using code
with distance d
then we say a circuit is for tolerance
uh if at the end of the circuit
the state in the code block remains
correctable
as long as there are no more than half
of d minus one circuit faults
that have occurred uh of course this is
a
um this is a very uh informal definition
but the key idea of tolerance
is to keep the error propagation
always under control
okay uh bearing this notion in mind
let's um
look at the short method for for
tolerance syndrome extraction
which is one of the most popular methods
people are using
below is a non-fault tolerance circuit
which measures x tensor 4. its issue is
that
all the four data qubits are coupled to
a single angular
so x fault in the middle will spread
into highway correlated error
one way to get around this
is to have four ancillars and couple
each data qubit separately
with an individual ancestor and this
type of coupling
is what we call a transversal so in this
transversal signal
a single x fault can never propagate
into correlated errors note that um
so so here um rather than uh plus states
here we
uh the sl should be uh should first be
prepared in this
four qubit cast state namely okay
zero zero
and at the end those uh synthetic bits
is evaluated
uh as the parity of the sum of these
four x basis measurements
uh now the issue remains that
how can we prepare such cat state
so here is a simple circuit that
prepares it
in the blue shade
however it suffers uh from the same
issue that
you have many c naught controlled on the
same qubit
for instance uh x fault in the middle
can propagate into correlated x errors
on the other side
and then it will propagate further to
damage the data block
so this circuit still is not far
tolerant
one solution for this is to use the
additional answer
here i it's a blue color to check
um if there are any correlated errors on
the cascade before
interacting with the data
note that we don't have to worry about c
errors on the answer because
only x errors can propagate to the data
and it turns out that these errors are
on the
first and the fourth answer is the only
possible correlated errors
arising from a single fault
and you can detect them by measuring the
parity of the first and the
second angulars recall that
the cast stage is a simply a repetition
code stabilized by
uh z1 and d2 so here we are marrying z1
z2
so the parity of the first term two cube
is uh
it's a change from even to all in other
words
this x fault uh will propagate
onto this verification ancestor and
result in
non-trivial measurement
so generally in short method you start
by
preparing a large cap state and then
measure the z tab check operators to
verify
there's no correlated errors and then
you perform this transversal signals
only foundation
on this measurement being trivial
so this is for tolerance syndrome
extraction certificate
which uses at least w plus one
considers where w is the weight of the
magnet stabilizer
okay now we are ready to to talk about
flag method so um
this is a naive approach to measure
uh say x to ten zero four uh with spare
and zero
it's not for tolerance because uh for
the x4
in the middle of the c naught can
propagate to the
data into correlated x errors
and previous approaches like schwarzman
get around this issue by
making xenon captain transversal but the
flag in flat paradigm
we allow this to happen the point is
that
we are able to calculate and crack them
so this is the flat gadgets colored in
blue
so the flag is initialized in states
cavaliero and the couple to the
syndrome is two synonyms and
finally measured in the policy basis if
there is no fault
then the gadget does nothing so you get
your syndrome bit here
and the z measurement on the flag is
trivial
and if x fault happens
it will still propagate badly to the
data but in the meantime
it also triggers the flag measurement to
be non-trivial
so basically the key for the flag
gadgets is to
catch all possible x faults
uh in between them and uh
this is a whole point of gadgets and
that is uh
actually the idea of the flag paradigm
uh but the the tricky thing is that uh
there are other
scenarios uh where the flag could be
triggered
for example uh the flag ancillary itself
could fail uh and um
you you can get uh non-trivial
measurements but
uh there's no data error at all
also export here uh will generate with
three data errors
but uh it is equivalent to x on the
first data cubits modulo the stabilizer
and similarly export here will generate
a weight 1 iron and this
xx error is really the only
correlated error that we have to correct
but the only thing we have observed is
this
triggered flag so how can we distinguish
between
these correlated errors with this with
one errors
well the solution is that we can measure
the stabilizers
to extract the syndromes of this unknown
flagged error we can
we should be able to distinguish these
flagged arrows
if they give rise to different syndromes
so to do this you have to carefully
design your flag gadgets
and in particular the other of the
synods within the flag
is really important so now let me
illustrate this idea
with an example suppose we are using the
15 cubic handling code
and want to measure one of its
stabilizer
x tensor eight uh which is supported on
the first
eight uh physical qubits
so here's a flag uh circuit that
measures it
uh i don't show uh all the 52-bit
because uh we are
only using the first eight of them so
so here uh we arrange all the c not
gates uh in this trivial order
and this flag gadgets um
it's supposed to catch x fault occurring
in the middle
now let's look at this specific export
uh in the middle of iceland vr
it will propagate through subsequent
signal gates
all the way down to the data cubits and
in this process is also triggered the
flag measurement to be
non-trivial and finally it will result
in
x errors on data previous uh five six
seven eight and you can verify that
this operator is not a stabilizer but it
has trigger syndrome
so in other words it commutes with all
stabilizers
and is a non-trivial logical operator
so in this case uh we should definitely
crack this
unwanted um logical error
however in another scenario where the
flag can be triggered simply by
environment faults on
itself so there's no data error
at all and in this case we should do
nothing
but there's no way that we can
distinguish this scenario
from this weight for logical error
so this circuit is not for tolerance
because
a single circuit fault gives rise to
a logical error it cannot detect so
um um how how do we solve this issue
well it turns out that we can simply
change
the order of these scene house example
uh we can switch these two c nodes and
switch this to xenons
still x in the middle will propagate
into a bit 4 correlated error
on the data however
the resulting data errors uh
in this case have a non-trivial syndrome
so this circuit is better than the
trivial order c naught
but it's not done yet here i
label all the circuit locations where
a single fault could trigger trigger
this flag
unfortunately if you write down
all the possible flag errors you can
verify that
they all have distinct syndromes so this
circuit is for tolerance
in the sense that they are able to
diagnose
the potential flat correlated errors by
its syndrome
and apply the correction accordingly
and so far we have considered only error
correcting
uh distance three code uh where we only
worry about
uh at most the one circuit fault and all
right we can ask a question
sorry so you did something that i got a
little confused
in on the previous slide somehow you
switched the order and i didn't
understand
exactly what was going there could you
say that one more time yeah
uh for nothing if you uh look at this uh
circuit it is a non-trivial uh order of
c naught
then uh this fault will propagate
uh into a correlated error with
this non-trivial syndrome and the
specific
uh correlated error actually depends on
the order here
right so uh you can compare this uh
slide this um like this case
if you if you change this to uh or these
two
then uh this uh
x fault will not propagate uh to
a qubit five instead it will propagate
on
um qb4
[Music]
so could you could you change the order
at random and it will work or is there
some specific rule
by which you change the order of c notes
um
yeah i mean you can easily i mean given
a signal order you can easily write down
the resulting propagated error but
you have to uh manually you
have to calculate its syndrome uh
when the aggregate is high then you
better
you definitely want it to have a
non-trivial syndrome
and that will depend on uh
the property of the code so
yeah so yeah that brings me
uh brings to uh next question
uh that uh uh actually so far
uh we have only considered um business
three where
uh we worry about single circuit
thoughts
and uh and for general
distance three codes uh it is a priority
on unknown
if um there exists any flag circuits
uh using only two answers uh this is
the reason is that for any specific code
we need to find a c naught
scheduling so that the flag errors
arising from
a single circuit fault are
distinguishable
so a natural question is a
how to design flag circuits that for
tolerantly
i require high distance calls uh it
seems
um quite different uh quite difficult uh
problem
uh because we need to deal with a
combination of
multiple circuit faults
uh the intuition of how to tackle
hypothesis
is uh is to protect the symptom insula
with more than
one flag gadget and in this way uh
the flag measurements will give you more
bits of
information and that will allow you to
better locate the critical force on the
uh syndrome incident
uh the getting principle for this uh
um is that we have to make sure the bad
thoughts are always
flagged and all possible flag errors
can be distinguished uh by either the
flag pattern
or their syndromes are combined together
in the recent work we use this intuition
and provide a flag error correction
scheme
that works for arbitrary stabilizer code
and our scheme still
measures one stabilizer at a time and
for distance d
code it use the flexor can use
at most this many um
at most the d plus one ancillars and in
particular
our circuit construction um does not
uh it's a it's explicit
and the order of the c notes
does not matter namely uh any c not
order
will be uh for tolerance
um okay so much for the arrow correction
now let's consider how to do fault
tolerance logical computation with flags
first let's recall how to perform
universal computation without using
error correcting code so universal gate
sites
can be generated by playful operations
supplemented
by any uh additional non-clifford
operation
uh so here clifford operation includes
preparation
caszero states and pay for group
unitaries generated by this gates
and also environments in the base z
basis
and the limitation of play for operation
is that
any computation using only clay for
operations
can be efficiently simulated on
classical computer
uh using the so-called polyframe updates
and
in fact using this rules all clever
unitaries can be
moved to the end of the circuit and
absorbed by the
final measurements so in principle you
can achieve
all the clitoral operations by only
preparing
cas0 and mirroring arbitrary poly
operators
and to achieve universality you need
one non-clifford operation one example
is to use
certain resource states called magic
states such as
t t state and h state alternatively
you can directly apply a unitary outside
the
playful group such as t t gates and the
control control
seagate or ccdk so in summary
for fault tolerance computation you need
to perform
um the logical versions uh of clay fur
or non-clifford operations over the
logical previous encoded
you know in the code so here are some
examples
where we can use flat gadgets to um
to make these logical operations for
tolerance for example in this
paper by uh hazuma known at all
the provider flag circuits to
photogrammetry matters
measure the logical poly operators of
cyclic
css codes and as we have seen
these environments are sufficient to
implement any
playful operations and in this
um two papers by chamberlain and all
uh they prepared the magic h states
using the seven uh seven two with steam
code and the color code respectively and
they do this by
for tolerantly measure the logical
hadamard operator
using flag circuits and finally
people explain record we consider the 15
cubic hamming code
and we construct logical cd and ccc
gates
using physical cd and ccd gates and to
make them for tolerance
they replace each physical case with the
corresponding gadgets
and another application of flag that i
want to mention is uh this recent paper
by triple de bruy and
ken brown where they extended the flag
idea
and construct more general flag gadgets
which can be used for magic state
distillation
and arbitrary angle poly rotations
which is a useful circuit for simulation
of quantum chemistry
and their flag gadgets serve as a array
mitigation
by catching a subset of errors within
the flag
from finally let me try to give some uh
broad perspective about flag for
tolerance in general
so a flag technique is useful uh
for designing a small flag um
small error correction or detection
schemes
uh which are useful for near term
for tolerance tests but it's also
interesting to
look at large uh infinite code families
and to
devise flag schemes for them for example
here are all the
uh so the partial list of uh examples
where uh for example um
timberland at all they look at the they
apply the flag
technique to the topological codes such
as
color codes and the divisor efficient
decoders
which take advantage of this
flag environment results to uh to
achieve better
uh decoding performance and uh
to come i want to conclude my talk with
a very
broad um uh
open question of uh um you know device
uh flag uh flag protocol
uh by uh taking into various uh
account uh by taking into account these
uh factors
like uh the number of uh ancient cubits
or the uh number of uh
heritage hex measurements required or if
you
are allowed if you are considering
parallelism
you may uh you may care about the
circuit depth
or um for the like for the super kind of
cubist platforms you you may want to you
may have
a limited qubit connectivity or degree
and also a major drawback of
our flag paradigm flag
scheme is that it use a lot of
intermediate measurements so if your
measurement time is long
and say the ideal incubate error is
not negligible then you certainly want
to
um use as many environments as possible
so um and also it's a
to develop flag schemes
uh specific for uh hardware's a higher
noise such as
biased or any bias noise for
like superconductors or quantum dots
or for uh isotropic errors
uh for uh triple ions and um
i think this uh uh
so so so that depends on
what's uh which of which find out this
is our uh
is your priority and how you uh
measure the trade-off between them and
um
yeah uh i think this is uh also a broad
question for not only for
uh flag but also for for tolerance in
general
so uh with that thank you very much for
attention well thank you
very that was a that was a fantastic
talk really clear
um let me uh let me turn to
um to our moderators to see if there's
any
uh if there are any questions
thank you have a question yes
um hi folks uh really i really enjoyed
your talk
and it occurred to me while you were
describing the flag
protocol that in many ways you could
consider it a classical
protocol where the insight is that
the error detection or error correction
protocol
can introduce more errors as long as you
find a way to
uniquely identify them and disambiguate
them
and um so at least in the examples you
give it's a purely classical protocol
are there examples of flag protocols
which are non-classical
um i'd say
in essence i i agree i agree with you
that currently um
at least for error correction the flag
schemes
is really a purely classical problem
but uh but for example for
if you want to if you look at the flag
gadgets
for a physical cct gate which is a
non-clever
uh non-clifford gate then um
you have to consider a linear
combination of
poly operators which um uh
which can be regarded as something
quantum but still
it's still it deals with you know poly
operators
um you can also say it's a it's a
classical problem
sorry man we're asking you know i mean
in
quantum error correction you always
correct in the
in the x and z basis so would you say
all of
error correction is just classic quantum
error correction is just classical
is is that the sense in which you meant
it or can i ask you to refine what you
were saying
ike i didn't quite understand honestly
i'll go ahead roy yeah yeah yeah yeah so
so here i
only consider um uh marrying poliax
x type operators but uh but
this is just for uh illustration purpose
but uh for general uh
scheme uh or general code you can
definitely measure
arbitrary uh stabilizer you want
uh which which is a mixed type and the
yeah but uh um
um yeah but
but the key is that uh uh you have to
choose
which stabilizer to measure carefully or
cleverly
so that the the resulting flag error
are distinguished uh distinguishable
somehow
um
thank you uh maybe i'll respond to image
and then hand it back to you really to
amplify more the i wanted to try to
understand this
from a more general perspective as
an idea which could be used for
non-stabilizer codes
because as you point out of course if
it's in this css framework then you just
do x and z
separately and it's just like two
classical codes
but if we think of flags as being the
concept that
the error correction procedure or
whatever procedure that's fault tolerant
can introduce
new errors as long as you can still
disambiguate them
then maybe it opens the door to being
used that way
for other kinds of codes like maybe you
could use that principle
to build fault tolerance into cws codes
etc yeah uh yeah yeah i i don't
see ws code but i
uh i don't know if there's any explicit
protocol for for doing computation
no not not that i know of and
and so maybe this could lead to
something like that
yeah yeah so so i guess flag the flag
idea can definitely
be applied to uh non-stabilizer codes if
uh i i think i think people like
chamberlain
they have they they consider using flag
to to error detect uh the gkp
code uh which is non-stabilized code as
i think i think that's a
uh interesting question so first you
have to uh
come up with a four tolerance criteria
for
for your physical system and then
you should come up with some you know
specific circuits
um yeah that implement that realize
that your logical operation and then you
can
devise flag gadgets to catch
um the creative critical force
that could have occurred yeah
thank you great thank you
i have a question kind of on a related
note um
is there kind of a general paradigm for
choosing this
uh c naught measurement order or
something like it seemed like
you had to very carefully figure out the
c naught measurement order so as to
disambiguate
um the different places the error could
have occurred is is there like a general
way of doing it so you have to custom do
it for each
kind of uh stabilizer code you're
looking at uh yeah
so so i think uh the the goal what we
want
the goal we want to achieve is to
distinguish the flag errors
and there are uh two uh two way
to achieve so first uh we can
uh we can use more flag gadgets
using more flag cubies so that
you know the more uh more flag gadgets
will give you more
information about uh you know the
different error could generate different
flag patterns so
so the second way is that
uh you can you can you can
extract the syndrome of the unknown
errors
but um but
uh but you know the syndrome will highly
depend on the code structure
itself so i think for general
code um it's very difficult
to to to to have a framework for finding
on the scene on order but the first
certain code
with a structured certain structure for
example for hamming code
uh they have shown that uh for all
having codes uh
uh maybe it will explicit
a c not ordering uh which is uh which
can give you
uh distinct uh syndromes for the flag
error are using only
uh two ancillars got it god thanks yeah
so it sounds like something that really
has to be done custom for each code
based on the particular structure yeah
so there's a question uh from harvey who
uh
it's are the two types of errors you
mentioned all that's possible in the
quantum system
um sorry um so what
are the two other errors uh
probably accidentators that's what hurry
means i'm not sure uh
i mean maybe how we can clarify oh yeah
maybe there's a yes okay so the question
is yes
the answer is to the question is yes
yeah are x and z the only two types of
errors
that are possible
okay um are there any other questions um
for rui
okay so maybe uh yeah it's
it's almost time for the panel so uh
let me just um about uh thank you roy
again that was a fantastic talk and
uh um okay so uh
let me just um uh let let's move on to
the panel now
so i i want to um you know at this point
i should be saying well
uh you know i'd like a distinguished
panel to step up to the front of the
stage but uh
you know what uh i think what that means
in in our case is that um
the the zoom experts here are going to
pin the videos of everybody on the panel
so
uh you know i just want to see john
martinez
and john prescott and peter shaw are
here as well as
as well as our two speakers from today
last week uh roy and
daniel gottisman so
um all right i'm gonna start pinning the
panelists right now so just a second
so um so while while that is being done
let me
let me introduce our uh very
distinguished panel
so um we are very really lucky to have
um um three of the giants in
in our field uh uh john martinez
uh john prescott and uh and peter shaw
uh john martinez you all know about
you know he's uh he's he's an
experimentalist
who worked on superconducting qubits and
he was the architect of
uh google's quantum supremacy experiment
um john fresco uh you know
we go back a long way he's he's one of
the earliest physicists to take quantum
computing seriously
uh he's worked on you know all aspects
of this
subject including error correction and
fault tolerance and
in many ways he's shaped the quantum
world we we
we work in today you know including
uh nisk and even the notion of quantum
supremacy
and then peter sure you know he needs no
introduction
he's uh he certainly revolutionized
quantum algorithms with his
with his uh quantum algorithms for
factoring and discrete log
but he's also the inventor of quantum
error correction and fault tolerance so
you know i really cannot think of three
better people to be on this panel
uh you know to talk to uh you know to
talk about these uh
discuss the two talks we had uh had
already
um so um you know in terms of the panel
uh the the uh you know the
the plan is to have uh each of the three
panelists uh you know give give a two to
three minute
um um sort of
talk discussing their views about about
these talks but also more generally
about
uh you know quantum layer correction and
fault tolerance
and then then we'll have a more general
discussion for a little while
between the panelists and the and the
and the speakers and
and then move on to questions from there
from the audience
um so um you know
before we start with the the individual
views uh
you know i i spoke to a few of my
colleagues about
what they would really like to hear
about uh given this unique opportunity
and
so let let me uh put out a few a few
ideas you know which you can feel free
to incorporate or not as you like in
your in your
uh in your remarks um so they range from
questions such as
uh could you could you say something
about you know how
how essential do you view uh fault
tolerance to
uh to uh getting to anything useful in
quantum computing you know is it an
essential first step or
do you think we can get somewhere first
um
uh to questions like uh can you
can you describe any any experiments
that would
in the near term or in the median term
that would probe some critical concepts
in
uh in in fault tolerance you know are
there are there specific experiments
that you would like to see or can
point to uh you know all the way from
there to
to questions about um in in our current
uh fault tolerance model
models for for the for the theoretical
results we assume
uh independent errors and so
you know do you do you think it's it's
time to move towards
fault tolerance in in in models where
they're correlated errors where you know
for instance with
uh it's super conducting qubits with
crosstalk or how important this
is that aspect and and then
you know then there's of course
questions about continuous
quantum error correction you know is
that is that something we should be
thinking about
so um with that let me just uh
turn the floor over to the panel and see
if um
you know who would like to go first
maybe
alphabetically john john martinez if you
think
okay well welcome to this file great uh
can you hear me okay yes okay
yes thank you very much uh for the
invitation
um there were several i had something to
say but i was going to say something
about
maybe a question or two of yours in
terms of doing experiments
one of the things that i worried about
was um
can we really as we build a big system
can we really
understand what the error rates are and
what the errors are
and you know you can maybe measure your
one and two qubit errors
but then when you run a big code are you
going to get that
and that's in fact the main reason for
me
doing the quantum supremacy experiment
was to run a complex
algorithm and check to see whether um
uh the error rates made sense and in
fact that was
probably the most astounding thing that
we discovered
in running that is that you could
predict
the net error rate that as measured by
cross-entropy fidelity
uh the system error rate which you know
the crossing agreement measures what's
the probability that
there were no errors in your whole um in
your whole
sequence running your your quantum
algorithm
and you could check that versus your
known single and two cubit errors and it
was quite good i i was actually quite
surprised
that it was quite predictive of it and
what this
means and you can check various issues
with that
but you can basically check that the
basic physics uh
is working right kind of thinking about
an error correction model
and to me this was uh this is really
great now when you run
an error correction you also have to
worry about correlated errors
and the cross-entropy benchmarking uh
experiment
if you have two errors whenever you know
you had one error you also had a second
error
you couldn't measure that okay so you
don't really measure correlated errors
use a measure
if there's one or more errors so that
still has to be checked
and that's of course very important for
quantum error correction
but uh i think that's you know super
important that that's looking good
and i expect that but there's another
question you know can we look for court
related errors
there's a paper coming out by the google
group
uh on correlated errors i think in next
week or so in nature communications and
there's an archive paper on it right now
that you can look up uh that looks at uh
leakage to let's say the two-state and
superconducting qubits
and it doesn't experiment to measure
that leakage and then do some
cubit reset to correct for that so there
is
there is some experimental work on that
and you know we were happy that
you know referees saw the importance of
that and and
uh accepted the paper and of course
fixed it up and it
proved it some so that's going to be out
there i think that's uh that's really
good
it would be useful uh for people to
start seeing data about that
uh and the the last thing i wanted to to
share
sorry if i'm taking too much time but i
like very much this last slide by the
speaker
where um uh you talked about
uh excuse me i'm trying to share here
uh talked about the specifications
a little bit and the thing is is when
you build
an error corrected system it's a systems
problem
there are many many things to think
about and get right
okay and there's a nice list there
here's a longer list
it's probably longer than this but these
are the things i think about
and uh you have to get many things right
so it's good people are thinking about
new codes trying to fix things up
but remember you have to do 10 maybe 20
things right
in order to make it useful for
experiment just going down the list you
need a good threshold
what's the qubit number for an
exponentially small error
what's the architecture specifically the
connectivity
more connectivity the harder it is to
build uh
error decoding complexity can you
actually do it
on let's say a super computer even uh
how to do one logical gate how to do c
knots how to do measurement
can you do your logical gates in
parallel because that's how computers
work
you want to make it fast uh can you do
long distance logical gates
g state distillation overhead and then
finally you're sensitive
uh to correlated errors and i have a
paper that came out recently talking
about
cosmic rays and uh cosmic rays uh
at least for solid-state qubits give you
correlated errors
and yeah you have to think about what's
going to happen there in fact you know
having
more qubits is a little bit better in
that case you don't want too many
but that's okay and i i give example of
the surface code and basically
the surface code meets all those things
uh in a way that's reasonable you can
imagine building something personally
you don't want to make it better and
that's great
uh but you know make sure you understand
all those issues i think is the main
thing
that i want to say is people explore uh
error correction codes different ones
you know what are all the system things
you have to worry about and are you
training off
you know something good for something
like really really bad in terms of doing
experiment
because basically if you have one of
these things that don't work well
then you're not going to use it
experimentally at least you know
to get to a big quantum computer
okay thank you thank you for uh letting
me share thanks john
uh i guess john preston
all right well first of all i want to
just take a moment to
celebrate what a marvelous idea quantum
era correction is
um some of the people on the panel like
peter and and dave and uh daniel and
some of the
people in the audience remember in the
mid 90s
how much skepticism there was from good
scientists about whether quantum
computing would ever be scalable and
they had
reasonable uh basis for that skepticism
they
physicists both experimentalists and
theorists understood in particular how
pervasive
decoherence is and
that we can at least theoretically
envision scaling up quantum systems to
arbitrarily large ones that we can
control we can make them do what we want
them to do
this is an amazing and great thing and
it has very broad implications in
in physics uh it's giving us new
insights into
uh phases of quantum matter
and even quantum gravity so i think this
is one of the
best examples we have of how the lens of
computer science and information theory
blended with physics
allows us to advance physics
it's really hard to do what should the
goal be you asked how essential is fault
tolerance
it's essential for the long-term future
of the field
um what is what's the goal well we'd
like uh
to be able using a fault tolerance to
execute algorithms which will
be a practical interest that we
wouldn't be able to reach without using
error correction
it's possible we'll be able to do it
interesting things with nist devices
without
error correction but there's no
guarantee of that so
it certainly has to continue to be of
you know focus of our field to
proceed to advance along that path
towards really a scalable quantum
computing
and uh underlying the two excellent
talks by daniel and rui was
uh what makes it extremely hard in
particular is the high
qubit overhead and they each in their
own way we're talking about how to
mitigate that uh daniel in a
sort of more futuristic way talking
about these higher rate
ldpc codes well it's important to think
about the future when we'll be able to
do those things
which might require lower qubit uh
gate error rates and higher connectivity
than with the current generation of
devices but eventually we'll be able to
do those things
and that's an important frontier for
theory and
really talking about the uh clever use
of ancillas through the flag paradigm to
reduce the cost and those are both
important things
um you asked about what experiments we
want to do
well following up on what john said
we need to benchmark error correcting
codes at the logical level we need to
see how well
we can execute uh logical circuits not
necessarily ones of practical interests
in the near term
this recent google experiment that john
mentioned
takes a good step in that direction
there now they're just doing the
repetition code it's not
really a quantum error correcting code
they can correct either the x
errors or the z errors but not both
simultaneously but what they were able
to do is
multiple rounds of syndrome measurement
up to 50 rounds and they were also able
to study how
as you increase the length of the code
the logical error rate
goes down more or less uh in accord with
expectations based on their
understanding of the noise in their
device
now there was crosstalk and they could
see it but you know error correction
still worked
up pretty well um what i'd really like
to see of course is
lower two-qubit uh
entanglement gate error rates uh that's
really a challenge that uh you know
error rates in both the
uh superconducting circuits and uh
the ion traps are a bit low one percent
not quite good enough
uh you know give me 10 to the minus
three ten to the minus four
and then uh then we're starting to get
somewhere and i realize how hard that is
but it's really an important goal and so
people should be
uh you know trying hard of course they
are
to improve those gate error rates
because that'll have a big impact on the
overhead cost of air correction and also
it'll enable us to do more uh
in the nist era and it's important to
continue running these things on
multiple platforms because they have
trade-offs pros and cons and we don't
know
at this stage of what's going in the
long term to have the best prospects for
scaling
so that continues to be important um
well
maybe uh i i guess i'd like to say a
little more
but i'll stop for now about um
you know how we might be able to improve
gate error rates and uh
get into an interesting regime with
quantum error correction uh sooner
but that's great that that's a fantastic
perspective we should definitely get
back
to what you know to you to discuss these
things so um
so peter yes so i'm first i want to say
that these
last two talks about flag qubits and
ldpc codes are really
you know great advances in the theory of
quantum era correction
and you can ask are there going to be a
lot more
advances in quantum error correction and
quantum fault tolerance and i think
there are
in fact if you look back at the theory
of
classical error correction shannon came
out in 1948
with his bound on how
good you could possibly do in terms of
classical error correcting codes
and for the next 40 years or so
people you know improved them but they
never got close to shannon's bound and
then
around 45 years after shannon's um paper
these three french engineers were you
know
basically trying to improve the
performance of convolutional codes and
had a clever idea
and they tried it out on their computer
and it came with a fraction of the
shannon bound
so they published it and
theoretical clothing theorists didn't
believe them
so then the theoretical coding theorists
coded it up too and it worked and it
took another five
ten years before anybody well
we still don't have a proof that the
original scheme works but we have a
proof that ldc peak classical codes
which are very similar to
the original turbo codes do work very
well
but they don't quite make the shannon
bound and then another
10 years later someone else
had a really clever idea and he came up
with polar codes
which probably met the shannon bound
and at first polar codes weren't
practical
at all but then people started working
on them and they are now
i think um going to be used in the next
generation
of um no cell telephones
so you know even
um 60 years after shannon's original
paper
people were improving the theory of
classical error correcting codes
so i think that there's lots more you
can do
to improve the theory of fault tolerant
error correction and if we do that
it will bring the actual um
implementation
of fault taller of
you know really useful quantum computers
a lot closer
i mean we still are going probably not
going to be able to
get good quantum error correction at one
percent error rate you probably need to
go down to 0.1 or 0.01
error rate to get really good error
correction but
i think you know
we don't we don't need to just
concentrate on the hardware we also
really need to concentrate on the theory
and the software
and it's possible you can even get more
um you know speed up from the software
than from the hardware
oh great yeah thanks peter so
let's just come on the last two things i
really liked
um the discussion about having how we
have to improve the two cubic date
errors
as many people know i've been harping on
that for
years and uh yeah um you know
it seems that you can build complex
systems with about a one percent error
rate
for two commit agents fairly readily and
then
uh there are isolated examples where
you're you're doing better than that
and we just need to continue uh can you
and it's it's just hard for
a variety of reasons to get there but uh
i do
have uh optimism that um
if you work hard enough you know we can
we can
bring down that number but i'm going to
say given that it's been you know many
many years experimentally that people
kind of
have been at this level it's going to be
hard
and i although i think you can get the
point one percent
you know maybe it's just gonna be really
really hard to get lower than that
so uh i think uh you know really efforts
on not just reducing the qubit number
but also
you know tolerating high error rates uh
you know around 0.1 percent what can you
do with that uh would be uh interesting
for people to understand that
we all hope that we can do better than
that but there's a chance that
you know we it's going to be really
really hard to get get much below that
and just just be aware of that that's a
possibility for the future
great so um let's see um
let me just ask people in the audience
to put in their
questions in in chat or in q a but in
the meantime
uh daniel or roy do you have any
anything to add before we turn to the
audience
um not really i mean i i i just
want to second some of the stuff that's
been said obviously
you know it in the vicinity of one
percent we can do error correction and
fall tolerance but there's
limited choices and you're kind of right
at the margin
um you get down to 0.1 uh or 0.01
then you have many more error correction
options and much more room
for for additional errors from various
things
um i think crosstalk something else
that's been mentioned a few times is uh
the good future frontier in in eric
correctional tolerance it's something
that hasn't really received enough
theoretical study yet of how how we deal
with that
fall tolerantly um i mean i know of one
paper by
john martinez and uh austin fowler that
that started it but there to be more i
think
great um
yeah i see that uh i like chung has a
has a question i don't know sure
this is a question for john prescott
more or less an excuse to let him
continue his thoughts
but john um another john von neumann
many years ago would have said about his
um computing infrastructure at the time
absolutely fault tolerance is necessary
we must study
our vacuum tubes to understand their
flaws intimately because
they are the future and photographers is
absolutely required
and as you know that didn't transpire we
have the
silicon transistor instead so what are
your thoughts are you going to be
obsolete in your thoughts in the same
way or
is there no option other than what we
have
well i think actually i would like to
believe that in the long run
we will have far far better
quantum hardware than we have now with
much
lower error rates and uh you know there
is some
vision of approaches that it might at
least move us in that direction
the best known being topological
quantum computing which is a brilliant
idea
uh and people have been pursuing it
aggressively
in the lab for 15 years and progress has
been very slow
that doesn't mean it's not going to
eventually
break through i think
doing error correction at the hardware
level
incorporating protection against noise
into the design of the hardware is a
really
important approach it will pan out
probably in the long run
but it might be the very long run we
don't really know of course
just like uh von neumann couldn't
anticipate very well
the uh the future of microchips
but i think chances are for
quite a while once we are able to do
quantum error correction
and perform quantum algorithms
that are really impactful uh
on society and people's lives that will
require quantum error correction until
sometime perhaps in the rather distant
future when the quantum hardware
by one means or another becomes such
high quality that error correction is
less important
i think you know um
if you can do better by even when if uh
physical
gate error rates are much lower if you
can extend the reach by doing quantum
error correction
uh if assuming the error rates are not
completely negligible then you'll want
to do that
so sorry john uh can can i um just uh
follow up uh
you ask your follower question which is
um um
you wouldn't say that there's something
very very different about quantum
information that makes
you know well you could say that in in
classical era correction it's
it's really the repetition code that
works that works for us in hardware
but with with quantum error correction i
think so different that
we you know we wouldn't expect the same
sort of uh
outcome where things become completely
stable just at the level without
of hardware or would you you know
where would you come come down on that
well you know for
for von neumann's original arguments
were based on the repetition code
uh there is uh you know a physics
setting in which the repetition code is
very
natural which uh you know is relevant to
actual hardware
that magnetic systems you know in two or
more dimensions have memory times which
scale very
favorably with the size of the system
you can think of that as a repetition
code but with highly redundant
uh checks which are uh you know provided
by the
dynamics of the system itself uh that's
kind of the
vision of topological quantum computing
as well that the
physical system should uh be
intrinsically
resistant to noise it doesn't really
work
uh even theoretically as far as we know
in just two spatial dimensions in the
same sense that uh
the repetition code can work in two or
three
spatial dimensions uh but it's uh it's
an open question i guess in three
dimensions whether we can make a staple
quantum memory
uh which can store uh quantum
information
for an indefinitely long period i think
that's also for theorists
uh an important question which could
have a big impact on the future of the
subject
great
are there any other other questions from
the audience
i think daniel has to get something off
his chest he's got a really deep frown
i was i was just looking there are some
questions i see in the q a
um one of them is what is the status of
topological qubits
which john started but didn't
say too much about do you want to say
more about it
oh this is back to me well i i didn't
hear that
well the status is that uh
the the current approach uh which dates
back
about 10 years to realizing
a uh a protected qubit using majorana
modes and a quantum
wire uh hasn't yet succeeded
and we don't still don't have a
protected qubit and you know
good scientists have been working
towards that
and uh you know eventually i think it's
going to succeed
when it first succeeds it won't be a
perfect qubit we
won't have uh you know arbitrarily low
gate error rates we'll use error
correction on top of it
the hope is that uh that approach will
lead
on a reasonable time scale to lower
gate error rates than other hardware
approaches
but evidently it's very hard part of the
challenge is
materials issues and this is a challenge
actually for
uh you know all the solid state
approaches
to quantum computing and uh those those
things take time to solve
great um there's one other person who
has a hand raised
a young romance can you
ask you a question
thank you very much sorry
i'm just speaking um
i meant very interesting talks thank you
very much so far
um i'm wondering
uh there's a lot of interest
in the ultimate goal of the majorana
qubit at the same time
shouldn't we have a kind of approach
in gradual improvements and
and once we achieve the logical
qubit level uh then maybe it becomes
easier to replace the underlying
hardware um
i mean we want progress instead of
waiting for the ultimate perfect
cubit um so
so i can uh comment on that and i would
say
um the approach that you know i was
thinking on
at google was to do exactly that
to use the surface code uh you know as a
as a prototype because it fit in
with the superconductivity and uh
the quantum supremacy was a milestone
along the way to make a 2d grid and do
the surface code
so there's this latest paper that gave
some information google's now working
on a you know a 2d uh version
uh so that you can actually correct bit
and and phase errors simultaneously and
repetitively
and uh so people are people are doing
that it's just hard that's why it's
it takes long but uh that will proceed
and you know when i when i was thinking
about that i had a vision how to scale
up to way more qubits
so that it would be possible to do it
multi-order and
understand uh the physics of this very
well
uh again the the big thing that has to
get
figured out is you know lowering the
error rate so that the
overhead is not so high again to around
0.1
but uh you know that was certainly my
vision and then i think that google is
continuing on with that vision
to to try that out and yeah that might
be the first steps to see what's going
on
and then when people invent something
better either hardware or
algorithms you can take what you learn
and uh
and then do that so i think that's
that's on people's
minds for the roadmap
so um you know i promised to circle back
to
john um you know uh john frasco
uh because um he had said he had these
uh
remarks he wanted to make um that he
didn't have time for so well
first of all just to follow up on the
last couple of comments
i mean we shouldn't think of topological
qubits as
for you know seeking the perfect cubit
and leaving the software approach behind
and what john was describing john
martinez is certainly you know something
that we've got to do
uh to take whatever the best hardware
we have that we can you know scale up to
a reasonable number of qubits and see
how well quantum error correction works
topological quantum computing is an
approach
to trying to get lower gate error rates
might not work
but it's important to pursue that in
other ideas the other idea i wanted to
mention
is uh the possibility
of using which uh the yale group has
been working on for years and lately
there's been i think a notable advance
on the theory side from the yale and
paris groups
is using the resonators and
superconducting circuits
as the depository of the qubits
and where the noise can be engineered
so that it's highly biased so and
one can cut so what that what what i
mean by that is you know we have z and x
errors like rui talked about in this
talk but where the z errors
are far more frequent than the x errors
we can concentrate
most of the air correcting power on
those frequent z errors
less on the uh less frequent x errors
and that can
lower the overhead cost of error
correction substantially
and the recent development that came as
a surprise to me is of course
you want to be sure
that your circuits don't propagate uh
the noise that occurs frequently
which your code is designed to correct
to the
you know less common errors which your
code doesn't protect against
as well and formally a c not gate is
good from that point of view because it
propagates x errors to x errors and z
errors to z errors but we have to
remember that
it's actually a physical process and so
you have to worry about
errors occurring during the execution of
the gate
and it turns out that in the
appropriate setting which i we don't
really have time to go into
uh the c9 gate even though noise is
occurring during the execution of the
gate if it's done the right way
can preserve that noise bias and so
of course this there are many challenges
associated with this approach
but i think it's an important one to
pursue and is promising because
if it indeed turns out to be the case
that we can scale up devices with highly
biased noise that could substantially
reduce the overhead cost
of doing error correction
dan has a question dan do you want to
ask it directly
so i guess the question is about um
modularity so i figured that
you know however big the the
next google chip is it's going to be a
finite sized chip
and then um you know true scaling is to
go
grow to infinity so you're going to have
to eventually learn how to connect
quantum computers to one another does
that present specifically new challenges
to error correction and fault tolerance
sure
i don't know it's always me okay oh yes
of course it does
and uh the um
it's particularly challenging for the
ion trap approach
where you know there's a limit to how
many ions you can put
in a single trap uh and you know still
maintain
uh good gait fidelities and
there are two solutions to that that
people are pursuing
one is to move the ions around in a
large system and then
have small modules in which the
processing occurs and then you need the
ability to move the ions around
without losing coherence then you have
to cool down their motion when they come
to wherever wherever you wanted to send
them
and the other approach is to um use
photonic interconnects to connect
uh traps together and they're you know
they're big challenges
um associated with both those things uh
it's important to
pursue those technologies as well and uh
you know those are
problems that it's gonna take time to
solve
yeah let me um let me make a comment
about super conducting qubits thinking
about this
um we thought that we could scale up to
say a thousand ten thousand qubits uh
using just the regular silicon wafer
what we're doing right now
uh which of course is big enough to do a
lot of testing on
getting low error rates and doing
logical gaits
and then to go beyond that you would
have to connect them together in some
way
uh and there was some simple simple
indian conceptually ways to do that but
you would have to develop a lot of ideas
to get that
work so there is kind of a pathway
forward on that
um but uh you know my view is you have
to
really get things working as you right
now
at 50 qubits whatever and then you have
to get it working over a thousand qubits
but there is a path forward there or
super common
john since you um since you went in in
that direction
can can i ask you what your ambitions
are moving forward you know
what what are you actually going to be
uh working on or trying to get to
what kind of hardware et cetera yeah
well
unfortunately because i had to leave
google um
i can't work on uh you know the big
systems that i would like to do
but uh i am working uh and i'm looking
at opportunities right now
but the big thing i've been working on
is fixing uh the error rates and making
them
smaller so i wrote paper on cosmic rays
and
correlated errors and i think we know
what to do there that looks good
and i'm also writing some papers and
working with robert mcdermott
on how to improve the individual qubit
errors and
and i have a have an idea on how to make
that but mostly what i'm going to do is
i'm just going to focus on that
issue because you know that's the
critical issues we
we have to do and you know what i did
for the last three
four years at google as i was working on
how to scale up
basically doing the wiring it sounds
really boring but that's what you have
to do to scale up
and i more or less know how to to how to
deal with with that
so um you know we're making progress it
just takes a long time to figure all
this stuff out
so i i did want to say something about
the kind of the
fault tolerance with uh with modular
systems i i think it's
it's um it's not fundamentally different
or new i mean i think we have
a lot of fault tolerance tools already
that can handle that
um it depends a lot on what kind of the
parameters the modularity are right if
it's very small
modules there's very big modules that
suggest totally different things
um it depends what the error rates
interconnecting different modules are
compared to the rates inside a module
and it depends on what the connectivity
is between different modules are so
you know you have to kind of look for
your specific system what those what
those three things are
and then maybe that also requires some
additional design
uh work to figure out what the right
fault tolerance architecture uses
uh for those for those parameters but um
and eventually you know once we
once that's all worked out maybe we'll
want to come up with even better ones
that
that are beyond the current tools but
but the tools exist
i think to deal with that yeah i was
really talking about the hardware
challenges more than that i mean
we need we want to have much higher uh
communication rates between modules say
than they currently do with the
ion traps
yeah and in my particular idea with the
superconducting system
uh it would be an interface between
modules that would
allow for fast uh community fast and
parallel communication
which again is is the kind of thing you
wanna you wanna
try to do i i agree though with the
sentiment that having
uh photonic interconnects so that you
can have separate really separate out
the modules
is a is a great direction but unless you
have the communication speed
and the you know which is the number of
bits two
or two bits that you're sharing then
that you know that becomes a bottleneck
so this is this is pretty far out you
know we have to get the basic modules to
work well
great um well um i think we are
getting to the end of the panel um let
me remind everybody that
we'll be on gather town at this point so
um
that should be um i think there's a
there'll be a link on the
chat if you don't already know um
so with that let me let me thank uh both
of our speakers for last week and this
week for
superb talks and to our distinguished
panel for
you know really great discussion um so
thank you everybody and see you in the
at gather town
um
you just make sure that there's the
other town link is down
okay so so you should be able to find
the
the link to gather town in the chat
oh my just a quick comment some of us
use a different device
to attend the talk um some of us use a
separate device to listen to the talk
and so it's actually
quite a i did it last time and i'm doing
it right now to
type the link onto a computer
where you can run get it out just a
quick feedback
on oh i see something technical
difficulty
yeah so how how would you suggest i mean
you can also get the link
if you just register on the on the
website okay
that's how we're the others but let me
let me let me uh
email it to you right now though sure
oh
okay and i guess i'll leave the zoom
open for a little while so
is it the same length every colloquium
yeah it is it is yes
so then i just need to uh get it right
once and
save that link somewhere okay all right
okay bye
so
okay so you should have it now
you